I thought it was smart you were doing
like a TV show all right and nobody
really thought of you from movies or
knew of you stuff didn't think you as an
adult even by being in Show Girls
whether it was a good movie or a bad
movie everybody was talking about you
that's true and you know and for all the
criticism at the time like here we are a
year later and they still talk about it
and you probably thought they hated it
so much and what did they say show girls
and Elizabeth bur you have total name
recogn and I thought at the time I said
man it was a Paul verhoven movie who's
like a real well-known director and
RoboCop right didn't he do RoboCop
recall I mean so to not have taken that
type of opportunity you got to be nuts I
find it remarkable that he didn't get
blamed for the movie you did I find that
remarkable well considering I didn't
write it or direct it or produce it you
know but you see like there were some
good actors in that movie but anyone
who's in a bad movie you think they can
act and unfortunately it's not like
let's say I had 10 other movies that you
could compare and say oh she's that and
that that and that so people thought oh
she's that character but the bottom line
is everybody knows the name Elizabeth
Berkeley now sometimes you wonder with
you know all that Talent going for it
and you know that kind of reputation on
the director and everything did it
looked that it was going to be that bad
in the midst of filming while you were
shooting did you think it was this is
the weirdest thing there was no
indication until literally the day
before really I'm telling you I went to
the can film festival I what you say
what about like when in dailies people
going hey this is great no they were so
inspired and loving it and the actual
process of making the film was amazing I
mean there was this this whole kind of
thing that was developing as far as the
heat on the movie and there was just no
indication until I think it was like it
was the day before it was released and
then the reviews came out and and I
went yeah that's the best way I can
describe when I
went you can't be good in a bad movie
well and the thing is you know what look
you you have to take risks I mean smart
I was one of the things is you know you
take risks and with that comes sometimes
a beating when you were getting blamed
for that movie I didn't blame you for
that movie you were in the movie big
deal I blame the director the guy who
wrote the script it's nobody's fault
they did did the best they could I'm
sure no they didn't so anyway but you
did you were a young actress wanting to
make it and you got your own starring
vehicle yes which I mean in it in it of
itself was pretty amazing especially
after the show you know I had made a
decision okay I don't want to do
television anymore and I had audition it
took like almost three years it was it
was tough there for a while so when you
went to audition for First Wives Club
they like oh you can't be in the movies
you were in the show Girls well I think
the hardest thing is you know people
have a lot of preconceived notions so
they think I'm going to be one specific
thing when in fact I'm not KNN as one
specific you know so I am but I'm very
shallow go
ahead